we all know the story of the Lord of the
Rings and its many heroes villains and
epic battles the story of the One Ring
itself however is a longer one with
history that stretches all the way back
to the beginning of JRR Tolkien's
fictional universe Sauron the actual
Lord of the Rings referred to in the
title of Tolkien's epic was created by
the deity era in the time before the
world was made in his early life he was
called my rom and served as a craftsman
to higher beings until he was corrupted
by Morgoth the original Dark Lord of
Tolkien's world Morgoth attempted to
conquer middle-earth in the first age
and when he was defeated myron fled
judgment hiding in middle-earth building
his power until he could make his next
move
the elves ultimately came to call him
Sauron as the centuries passed
Sauron began calling himself the Lord of
gifts and visited the elves though some
of the elves including Galadriel and
Elrond distrusted him the elven Smith
quella brim Bor was taken with sour ons
gifts and together they began forging
the rings of power they eventually gave
19 rings to the races of middle-earth
Sauron forged the One Ring in the
volcanic fires of Mount Doom pouring
much of his own essence and power into
it the plan was to use the one to
control the wearers of the other rings
unfortunately for Sauron the ring
bearing elves were able to sense the
presence of the Dark Lord and avoid his
control leading to a war against Sauron
for the Rings of power the war finally
ended when an army of men joined with
the elves Sauron retreated back to
Mordor to recover more centuries past as
Sauron continued to fortify his
stronghold in Mordor and completed the
tower of bara door near the end of the
Second Age he was strong enough to again
attempt conquest of middle-earth
but the armies of númenor the nation of
men marched against him
Sauron surrendered and was taken as
prisoner but he was not humbled by his
supposed defeat in Numenor Sauron again
assumed a beautiful appearance and
convinced the númenóreans that they
should worship his old master Morgoth
it was here that arrrooo the supreme
creator of all intervened Numenor sank
into the sea its armies were drowned and
saurons physical form was too
his spirit however was able to return to
Mordor tied to the material world by the
one ring led by lnd love the survivors
of númenor escaped to middle-earth
Sauron watched the formation of their
kingdoms and his hatred of lndia led him
to attack lndia and his sons including a
seal door knew they couldn't battle
Sauron alone and formed the last
alliance with the elves to make a stand
against the darkness the siege of bara
door lasted for years until Sauron
finally came out to join the fight
himself it was then that he sealed or
took up his father's sword
narshall and cut the One Ring from
saurons hand Sauron was defeated and the
victory marked the end of the Second Age
sadly a seal door was seduced by the one
rings power and kept it for himself only
losing it when he was killed in an
ambush by orcs the ring vanished into a
river and would not be seen again for
centuries for more than 2,000 years the
One Ring was lost that changed the day
to cousins Smeagol and deagle went
fishing near the spot where he sealed or
was killed there deagle discovered a
gold ring in the water Smeagol was
immediately drawn in by the one rings
power and when deagle refused to give it
to him Smeagol responded by strangling
his cousin and taking the One Ring for
himself
[Music]
ma pression with the ring granting him
an endless life he spent 500 years alone
in the dark as his body and mind were
twisted by the ring over time he came to
be known as Gollum Gollum and his ring
lived in seclusion for centuries until a
hobbit named Bilbo Baggins accidentally
stumbled across the creatures lair while
lost in the Misty Mountains Bilbo found
the ring in the dark and used it to
escape Gollum after a riddle contest at
which quite frankly
Bilbo cheated
[Music]
pocket
it's no fun though he initially lied
about the ring Bilbo didn't chew elite l
the wizard Gandalf the gray more details
about how he came to possess it Gandalf
was able to deduce that it was one of
Sal Ron's evil rings of power still the
wizard decided the ring was relatively
safe in the hobbits hands leaving Bilbo
to keep it at his home in the Shire
Bilbo kept the ring for decades
intending to one day leave it to his
nephew Frodo with Gandalf's blessing
when the time came though
Bilbo seemed reluctant to part with it
this led Gandalf to realize that Bilbo's
ring was not just one of the magic rings
but the ring Sal Ron's long-lost one
ring the danger of the One Ring itself
coupled with golems recent emergence in
middle-earth and the return of the dark
forces like the ring wraiths led Gandalf
back to the Shire to warn Frodo he told
the young Hobbit to set out for the
elven city of Rivendell where Elrond was
assembling a council they decided that
the ring must be taken to Mordor to be
destroyed in the fires of Mount Doom as
it was the only way to prevent Sauron
from eventually reclaiming it Frodo
volunteered to be the one to take it and
was joined in his quest by others you
have my sword
[Music]
that you have lipo
my the Fellowship of the Ring as Frodo's
group was now known set out from
Rivendell while agents of Sauron
continued to pursue them and amass
forces leading to tragedy for the group
power your foolish later when the
fellowship was attacked by orc warriors
Boromir
a noble soldier of Gondor was killed
while defending the lives of the hobbits
before he died however Boromir succumbed
to temptation and tried to take the ring
from Frodo which led Frodo to believe he
needed to leave in order to spare his
allies the burden of the Rings power Sam
refused to let Frodo go alone and so the
two ventured off to Mordor together when
Frodo and Sam became lost trying to find
the way to Mordor they realized that
Gollum who had been set free after
torture at the hands of the orcs was
following them after capturing him Frodo
and Sam ordered him to lead them to
Mordor a task he agreed to in order to
stay close to the ring eventually Frodo
Sam and Gollum made their way into Sal
Ron's dark realm war erupted all around
them as the remainder of the Fellowship
continued to battle orcish armies in a
bid to buy Frodo time to destroy the
ring Gollum meanwhile continued to plot
against the hobbits in order to retake
the ring for himself in his bid to
eliminate the hobbits Gollum led them to
what he claimed was a shortcut to Mount
Doom in fact it was the lair of the
giant spider Shelob who nearly killed
the hobbits when Sam and Frodo finally
reached the fires of doom Frodo gave in
to the Rings power and put it on
refusing to destroy it it was here that
Gollum made his move pouncing on Frodo
and biting off the finger that held the
ring Gollum reunited with his precious
at last was too lost in celebration to
see where he was standing he fell off
the edge into the magma below destroying
himself and the One Ring
Sauron whose essence was directly tied
to the ring was defeated and all of his
armies instantly collapsed check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite franchises are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single
[Music]